you'd say go on you like a sharp cheddar
yeah
how many of them look it's can still
only name sharp cheddar I know Jin yeah
but you know Brenda was hoping to pull a
different cheese out of his brain I love
cheese in you you cannot brush yes I can
do it right now right now I'll go then
you go ready oh he gets to start with
here go ready Swiss bro i provolone baby
parmesan nobody else dude that's what
I'm saying
parmesan let me see yackety-yak pepper
jack sharp cheddar
what was just going we're going serial
killer cheese bro let me go with that
why air boy everybody that Becky breeze
that a real thing baby bro his retreat
he's gonna break if they want real trees
nature god dude sometimes I got the
rhythm and sometimes I got the blue
cheese
[Applause]
he's good and he's bad because I'm
[Laughter]
[ __ ] what's up with that my cheddar
that sweet red chatter I got chatters
all day bro sweet red [ __ ] that's that's
real real it's real I buy it
it's from England it's sweet rich other
foods dude right there sweet red oh no
no that's a type of cheddar I promise
it's it the company's called something
else oh you scroll in sweet red LLC
right now scroll in companies called
somerdale or something like that
some are Dale sweet red cheddar suck
this real cheese though yeah that's all
I buy it's another chatter no it's
another different type if we had to go
the judges I don't know guys let's go to
the cheese Chinese over here what are we
doing raising somebody yes how about
asiago cheese Mulligan this is a type of
cheese I've just given out for while
you're still [ __ ] Scooby red that's a
cheese that's a [ __ ] hookers a
nickname brah that's a real cheese brah
you don't need your cheese I'll see
y'all go for the win that's your mom
calling to give you more ideas no oh
it's yellow off ask him Oh yellow
cheddar yellow do something dude or oh
[ __ ] I just slipped on some what was
that Oh cream cheese
[Applause]
[Music]
is that a real cheese okay I mean that's
the thing man it's like we getting you
know is it a real cheese brie cheese
that counts
that's your hind up I don't know if it
does but is it a just a style of cheese
you know we kind of know our cheese's
though don't we I don't know I can't
remember if you said this one or not
just play it that bad mother mozzarella
hmm
did we played that one did we or not I
don't think and I got an A now just now
I'm going are you
I got that [ __ ] Oh string cheese
string cheese it's a band okay [ __ ] what
it is good type of cheese that's all I
know that string let's move on Doug did
know what 20 minutes go over cheese you
did six on your ass to go with sweet rag
from England bro chin you like a sharp
cheddar check that [ __ ] out
back up my broccolini get your life
together
I'm not touching